8 heures c'est parti pour le grand
marathon des soldes dans ce centre
commercial athlètes des clayes-sous-bois
cette période représente 20% du chiffre
d'affaires annuel
cette année elle s'annonce
particulièrement importante suite aux
intempéries ou les ventes étaient en
baisse
alors pour attirer les clients vers
leurs boutiques les commerçants mettent
en place des opérations spéciales
aujourd'hui on a démarré les soldes à 8h
en offrant une envie supplémentaire de
10% sur toutes les boutiques
supplémentaires sur les soldes et nous
avons faire un petit déjeuner dans tous
nos restaurants
une preuve que ces opérations marketing
fonctionne bien une heure après
l'ouverture des soldes
la fréquentation a déjà augmenté de 20%
les clients répondent présents et sont
ravis
c'est formidable on est accueilli avec
un petit déjeuner il n'y a pas trop de
monde il fait beau que du bonheur je
trouve que c'est sympa parce que surtout
que vous proposez le petit déjeuner
c'est super on passe un bon moment avant
attaquer les soldes donc je sais bien
très bien très calme en plus donc c'est
très agréable on a des réductions
supplémentaires en venant tous beaucoup
s'est levé tôt les ventes privées et le
e-commerce défavorise parfois les soldes
mais auch et n'ai pas d'inquiétude les
180 enseignes du centre sont confiantes
les soldes restent un rendez vous
incontournable comme le premier semestre
a été un petit peu compliqué en raison
effectivement d'un climat social chargé
d'une météo qui a été si peu clémente
forcément il ya du stock
il ya une envie de vendre de faire la
place pour nouvelle collection et les
clients aussi en vue de s'équiper pour
avant de partir en vacances mon cas il
ya un enthousiasme une envie partagée
d'une façon générale on n'a pas trop à
se plaindre vu l'historique de notre
magasin on arrive à tenir nos chiffres
régulièrement et ce depuis un certain
nombre d'années pour les soldes de cet
été le panier moyen des français devrait
s'élever à 300 euros soit une
augmentation de 55 euros par rapport à
l'année dernière